what is assembly theory
and generally speaking how would we
recognize life
if we saw it so assembly theory is a
theory
goes back a few years now my struggle
for maybe almost 10 years
when i was going to origin of life
conferences and artificial life
conferences where i thought that
everybody was dancing around
the problem of what life is and what it
does
but i'll tell you about what assembly
theory is because i think it's easier so
assembly theory literally says if you
take an object
any given object
and you are able to break that object
into parts very gently so just maybe
let's say take a piece of very intricate
chinese porcelain and you tap it just on
the hammer or the nail at some point and
it will fragment into many parts
and if that object is able to fragment
into many and you count those num those
parts the different parts so they're
unsymmetrical
assembly theory says
the the larger the number of parts
unsymmetrical parts that object has
the more likely it is that object has
been created by an evolutionary or
information process
especially if that object is not one-off
you've got a an abundance of them
and that's really important the abundant
i and i so because if you what i'm
literally saying about the abundance if
you have a one-off object and you break
it into parts
and it has lots of lots of parts you'd
say well that's
that could be
incredibly intricate and complex
but it could be just random
and i was troubled with this for years
because i saw in reality that assembly
theory worked but when i talked to very
good computational
um complexity computationalists
algorithmic complexity people they said
you haven't really done this properly
haven't thought about it it's like this
this is the random problem
and so i kept working this up because i
invented an assembly theory
in chemistry first of all with molecules
and so the thought experiment was
how complex does a molecule need to be
when i find it that it couldn't possibly
have risen by chance probabilistically
and if i found this molecule able to
detect it enough quantities in the same
object like a machine like a mass
spectrometer so typically in a mass
spectrometer you weigh the molecules
electric field you probably have to have
the order of 10 000 identical molecules
to get a signal so 10 000 identical
molecules that are complex
what is the chance of them occurring by
chance
well we can do the math let's take a
molecule like strychnine or um
or
yeah so stricken is a good molecule
actually to take
or viagra is a good molecule i made
jokes about viagra because it's complex
molecule and one of my friends said yeah
if we find viagra on mars in detectable
quantities we know something is up
yeah but anyway it's a complex molecule
so what you do is you take this molecule
in the mass spectrometer and you hit it
with some electrons or an electric field
it breaks apart
and if the larger than the larger the
number of different parts you know
when it starts to get to a threshold my
idea was that that molecule could not be
created by chance probabilistically
so that was where assembly thought
theory was born in an experiment in a
mass spec experiment and i was thinking
about this because nasa's sending mass
spectrometers to mars to titan
is going to send them to europa there's
going to be a nuclear-powered mass
spectrometer they're going to tighten
this i mean this is the coolest
experiment ever they're not only sending
a drone that's going to fly around titan
it's going to be drill powered by a you
know
a nuclear slug a nuclear battery and
it's going to have a mass spectrometer
on it is this already launched no it's
going it's dragonfly and it's going to
be launched in a few years i think it
got pushed a year because of the
pandemic so i think you three or four
years fly
nuclear dragonfly is going to fly to
titan
uh and collect
uh
data about the composition
of the various chemicals on titan yeah
i'm trying to convince nasa i don't know
if i'll be able to convince the dragon
fly team
um that they should apply this approach
but they will get data and depending on
how good their mass spectrometer is but
i had this thought experiment anyway i
did this thought experiment
and for me it seemed to work i i turned
the thought experiment into an algorithm
in assembly theory and i basically
assembly theory if i take let's just
make it generic and let's just take the
word abracadabra say can i
um if you find the word so if you have a
book with lots of words in it and you
find abracadabra one off and it's a wrap
book that's been written by in a random
way you know a set of monkeys in a room
and you know head type and you're on
typewriters and you find one or fabric
adapter no big deal but if you find lots
of reoccurrences of abracadabra well
that means something weird is going on
but let's think about the assembly
number of abracadabra so
abracadabra has a you know uh has a
number of letters in it you can break it
down so you just cut the letters up
but when you actually reassemble
abracadabra the minimum number of ways
of organizing those letters so you'd
have an a a b
you know
and keep going up
um there's just the you can when you cut
abracadabra up into parts you can put it
together again in seven steps so what
does that mean that means if you
basically don't re you're allowed to
reuse things you make in the chain at
the beginning
that's the memory of the universe the
process that makes abracadabra
and because that causal chain you can
then get to abracadabra quicker than the
number of letters for having to specify
only in seven
so if you take that to a molecule and
you cut the molecule up
into parts
and you can on the causal chain and you
basically start with the atoms and then
bonds and then you randomly add on those
parts to make the a make the b make the
and keep going all the way up
um i found that literally assembly
theory allows me to say how compressed a
molecule is
so when there's some information in
there
um and i realize that assembly theory is
it wasn't isn't just
confined to molecular space it can apply
to anything but let me finish the
molecular argument so what i did is i
i had this theory i was one of my one of
my students we wrote an algorithm we
basically took the 20 million molecules
from the database and we just calculate
their assembly number
and that's the index like basically
if i take a molecule and i cut it up
into bonds what is the minimum number of
steps i need to take to reform that
molecule from atoms so reusability of
previously formed things is somehow
fundamental exactly so it's like a
memory in the universe right i'm making
lots of leaps here like it's kind of
weird i'm saying right there's a process
that can form the a and the b and the c
let's say and then that when there's and
because we've formed a and b before we
can use a and b again with no extra cost
except one unit
so that's the kind of what the chain of
events and that's how you think about
memory here when you say the universe
when you talk about the universe and or
life is the universe
creating memory exactly so we we went
through chemical space and we looked at
the assembly numbers we were able to
classify it we said okay
let's test it let's go
so we're able to take a whole bunch of
molecules and assign an assembly index
to them
okay and it's just those as a function
of the number of bonds in the molecule
how much symmetry so literally assembly
theory is a measure of how little
symmetry a molecule has so the more
asymmetry the more information the more
weird it is like a jackson pollock or
some description so i then went
and did a load of experiments and i
basically took those molecules i cut
them up in the mass spec and measured
the number of peaks without any
knowledge of the molecule
and we found the assembly num then the
there was a almost uh
not quite a one-to-one correlation but
almost because not all bonds are equal
they have different energies i then did
this using two other spectroscopic
techniques nmr nuclear magnetic
resonance which uses radio frequency to
to basically jangle the molecules and
get a signature out and i also used
infrared
and infrared and nmr almost gave us a
one-to-one correlation so what am i
saying
saying by
taking a molecule and do it and and
doing either infrared or nmr or mass
spec
i can work out
how many parts there are in that
molecule and then put it on a scale
and what we did
in the next part of the work
is um we took molecules randomly from
the environment from outer space from
all around earth from the the the from
the sea from antarctica
and from fossils and so on and even nasa
and they because they didn't believe us
blinded some samples
and that we found that all these samples
that
came from biology
produce molecules that had a very high
assembly number above a threshold of
about 15.
so basically
all the other stuff that came from that
ebiotic origin
was low there was no complexity there so
we suddenly realized that on earth at
least there is a cut off that
natural phenomena
cannot produce molecules that need more
than 15 steps to make them
so i realized that this is a way to make
a scale of life a scale of technology as
well
and
literally you could just go sniffing for
molecules off earth on titan on mars and
when you find a molecule in the mass
spectrometer that gives you more than 15
parts
you'll know
pretty much for sure that it had to be
produced by evolution
and this allowed me to come up with a
general definition of life based on
assembly theory to say that if i find an
object
that has a that has a large number of
parts say an iphone or boeing 747 or you
know
any complex object and i can find it in
abundance and cut it up
um i can tell you whether that has been
produced by an informational process or
not and that's what assembly theory kind
of does
but it goes a bit further
i then realized that this isn't just
about life it's about causation
so actually it tells you about whether
there's a causal structure so now i can
look at objects in the universe say that
again this cup and say right i'm going
to look at how many independent parts it
has
so that's the assembly number
i'll then look at the abundance how many
cups are two on this table maybe there's
a few more you got stashed away so
assembly is a is a function of
the complexity of the object
times the number of copy numbers of that
object or a function of the copy number
normalized so i realize there's a new
quantity in the universe you have energy
entropy and assembly
so assembly the way we should think
about that is uh how much uh reusability
there is
because
reusability is like the like can you
play devil's advocate to this so like
could this just be
a nice
tertiary signal
for living organisms like some kind of
distant signal that's
yeah this is a nice property but it's
not capturing something fundamental or
do you think reusability is something
fundamental to the life and complex
organisms i think reusability is
fundamental in the universe not just for
life and complex or organisms it's about
causation
so i think assembly tells you if you
find objects because you can do this
reject trajectories as well you think
about it that
in the unit the fact there are objects
in the universe on earth his mind is
weird
you think about it we should just have a
commentary explosion of stuff
the fact that
not everything exists
is
is really weird
now
and then
as i'm looking at two mugs and two water
bottles
and uh the things that exist kind of
uh
are similar and multiply
yeah in copies yeah yeah so i would say
that assembly allows you to do something
that statistical mechanics
and people looking at entropy have got
stuck with yeah for a while
so i'm making it's pretty bold i mean
i'm writing a paper with sarah walker on
this at the moment
and we're realizing we don't want to get
ahead of ourselves because i think that
there's lots of ways where this
is you know it's it's a really
interesting idea it works for molecules
and it appears to work for any objects
produced by causation because you can
take a motor car you can look at the
assembly of the motor car look at a book
look at the assembly of the book
assembly theory tells you there's a way
of
compressing and reusing and so when
people i talk to
information theorists they say oh this
is just logical depth i say it is
like logical depth but it's
experimentally measurable
they say oh it's a bit like common
goller of complexity and say but it's
computable
and now okay it's not infinitely
computable gets mp hard very quickly
right it's very hard problem when you
get but it's uncomputable enough
you're contractible enough to be able to
tell the difference between a molecule
that's been formed by the random
background and by
causation and and i think that that's
really interesting because
until now there's no way of measuring
complexity objectively
complexity is required
algorithmic comparisons and programs
and human beings to label things
assembly is label-free
well not entirely we can talk about what
that means in a minute
okay um my my brain has been uh
broken a couple of times sorry i
explained that really badly no it was
very well explained it was just
fascinating and uh
it's uh
it's a my brain is broken into pieces
and i'm trying to assemble it uh so np
hard
so when you have a molecule
you're trying to figure out okay
if we were to reuse parts of this
molecule which parts can we
reuse
to
uh as an optimization problem and be
hard
to figure out the minimum amount of
reused components
that will create this molecule
and it becomes difficult when you start
to look at a huge huge molecules
arbitrarily large yeah because i'm also
like mapping this can i can i think
about this
in complexity generally like looking at
a cellular automata system and saying
like what's the what can this be used as
a measure of complexity for like a
arbitrarily complicated system
yeah i think it can it can and i think
that the question is and what's the
benefit because there's plenty of
um i mean in computer science and
mathematics and in physics people have
been
really seriously studying complexity for
a long time
and i think there's a really interesting
problems of where we course grade
and we lose information and all assembly
theory does really assembly theory just
explains weak immersions
and and so what assembly theory says
look
going from the atoms into atoms that
interact those first replicators that
build one another
um assembly at the the minimal level
just tells you evidence that there's
been replication and selection
and i think the more selected something
is the higher the assembly
and so we we're able to start to know
how to look for selection in the
universe if you go to the moon there's
nothing a very high assembly on the moon
except the human artifacts we've left
there
so again let's go back to the sandbox
in assembly theory says
if all the sand grains could stick
together that's the infinite conventory
explosion in the universe that should be
the default well we don't have that now
let's assemble sand grains together and
let's um and do them in every possible
way so we have a series of minimal
operations that can move the sand
together but all that doesn't exist
either now because we have specific
memory we say what we're going to put
three sand grains in a line or four and
make a cross or a triangle or something
unsymmetrical and once we've made the
triangle and the unsymmetrical thing we
remember that we can use it again
because on that causal chain
so what assembly theory allows you to do
is go to the actual object that you
exist you find in space and actually the
way you get there is by disassembling it
so
disassembly theory works by
disassembling objects you have and
understanding that the steps to create
them and it works with map
for molecules beautifully because you
just break bonds
but like you said it's not be hard it's
very difficult it's a difficult problem
to figure out how to break them apart
for molecules it's easy if you just keep
low enough in molecular weight space
it's good enough so it's a complete
theory
when we start to think about objects we
can start to assign we can start to
think about things at different levels
different atoms what do you assign as
your atom
so in a molecule the atom this is really
confusing because the word atom i mean
smallest breakable part so in a molecule
the atom is the bond
because you break bonds not atoms right
right so in a car the atom might be i
don't know a small amount of iron or the
smallest you know reusable part a rivet
uh a piece of plastic or something so
you've got to be really careful in a
microprocessor the atoms might be
transistors
and so
how are some the amount of assembly as
something as is a function you have to
look at the the atom level what are you
so where are your parts what are you
counting that's one of the things you
get to choose
what is uh what scales down what is the
minimum exact thing i mean there's a
huge amount of trade-offs in
when you approach a system and try to
analyze like if you approach earth
you're an alien civilization try to
study earth what is the atom for trying
to measure the complexity of of life
is it uh are humans the atoms i would
say to start with you just use molecules
i can say for sure if there are
molecules of sufficient complexity on
earth then i know that life has made
them and then go further and show
technology there are molecules that
exist
on earth that are not possible even by
biology you needed technology and you
needed microprocessors to get there
so that's really cool and that there's a
correlation between
that uh between the the coolness of that
and assembly number whatever the measure
what's the what would you call the
measure assembly index yeah so yeah so
there are three kind of fundamental kind
of labels we haven't so there's the
quantity of assembly and the assembly
that the so if you have a box let's just
have a box of molecules so i'm going to
have my box
we count the number of identical
molecules and then we chop each molecule
up in a individual molecule class and
calculate the assembly number so
basically
you then
have a function that sums over all the
molecules for each assembly and then you
divide through so you make it uh divide
through by the number of of of molecules
so that's the assembly index for the box
so that will tell you the amount of
assembly in the box so basically the
assembly equation we come up with is
like basically the sum
of e to the power of the assembly index
for molecule i times the number of
copies of the molecule i
and then you normalize you sum them all
up and then normalize
so some boxes are going to be more
assembled than others
yeah that's what they tell me so if you
were to look at me as a box so say i'm a
box
uh am i at some of my parts
in terms of like how do you know what
what's my assembly index so
gentle so let's just we'll talk about
the molecules and use so let's just take
a pile of sand the same way as you
and i and i and i would
um take you and just cut up all the
molecules
i mean and and look at the number of
copies an assembly number so in sand
let's say there's probably going to be
nothing more than a semi number of two
or three
but there might be trillions and
trillions of sand grains and your body
there might be the assembly numbers
going to be higher but there might not
be quite as many copies because the the
molecular weight is higher
so you do want to average it out you
kind of you can do averages i'm not i'm
not defined by the most impressive model
no no you're an average and you're
volume what i mean we're just working
this out but what's really cool
is they're you're gonna have a really
high assembly
the sand will have a very low assembly
your causal power
is much higher you get to make decisions
you're alive you're aspiring assembly
says something about causal power in the
universe
and that's not supposed to exist
because physicists don't accept that
causation exists at the bottom
you